welcome to the presentation on systems
of linear equations so let's let's get
started and see what this is all about
so let's say i had two equations now the
first equation let me write it as
9
x
minus 4
y
equals minus 78
and the second question the second
equation
i will write as 4x
plus y is equal to minus 18.
now what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to use both equations to
solve for x and y we are we already know
that if you have one equation and has
one variable it's very easy to solve for
that one variable but now we have two
equations you can almost use two
constraints and we're going to solve for
both
both variables and and you might be a
little confused but how does that work
how is it just magic that two equations
can solve for two variables well it's
not because you could actually rearrange
each of these equations so that they
look kind of in the normal y equals mx
plus b format and i'm not going to draw
these actual two equations because i
don't know what they look like but if
this was a coordinate axis and i don't
know what that first line actually does
look like we could do another module
where we figured out but let's just say
for sake of argument that that first
line all the x's and y's that satisfy 9x
minus 4y equals negative 78 let's say it
looks something like that
and let's say all of the x's and y's
that satisfy that second equation y
4x plus y equals negative 18. let's say
that looks something like this
right
so
on a line is all of the x's and y's that
satisfy this equation and on the green
line are all the x's and y's that
satisfy this equation but there's only
one pair of x and y that satisfy satisfy
both equations and and you can guess
where that is that's right here right
whatever whatever that point is i'll do
it in pink for emphasis
whatever this point is notice it's on
both lines so whatever x and y that is
would be the solution to this system of
equations so let's actually figure out
how to do that
so what we want to do is eliminate a
variable because if we can eliminate a
variable then then we can just solve for
the one that's left over and the way to
do that let's say i want to eliminate
i feel like eliminating this y and i
think you'll get an intuition for how we
can do that later on and the way i'm
going to do that is i'm going to make it
so that when i add this to this they
cancel out well they don't cancel out
right now so i have to multiply this
bottom equation by 4 and i think it'll
be obvious why i'm doing it so let's
multiply this bottom equation by 4
and i get
16 x
plus 4y
is equal to let's see 40 plus 32 minus
72.
right all i did is i multiplied both
sides of this equation by 4 right and
you have to multiply every term because
it's distributive property and both both
sides whatever you do one side after the
other let me rewrite that top equation
again and i'll write in the same color
just so we can keep track of things 9x
minus 4y
is equal to minus
78.
okay
well now
if we were to add these two equations
when you add equations you just add the
left side and you add the right side
well when you add you have 16x plus 9x
well that equals
25x
all right 16 plus 9.
4y
minus 4 that just equals 0 so that's
plus 0
equals and then we have
minus 72
minus 78.
so let's see that's minus
140 150 minus 150
right we're just adding them all
together so we have 25 x
equals 150
well we just we could just divide both
sides by 25 or multiply both sides by 1
over 25 it's the same thing and you get
x equals
that's a negative 150 x equals minus 6.
now we solve
the x coordinate
now to solve the y coordinate we can
just use either one of these equations
up at top so let's use this one because
it seems a little bit marginally simpler
so we just substitute the x back in
there
and we get 4
times
minus 6
plus
y
is equal to minus 18.
and i'll go up here 4 times minus 6 we
get minus 24
plus y
is equal to minus 18.
negative y is equal to 24 minus 18. so y
is equal to 6.
so these two lines or these two
equations you could even say intersect
at the point x is minus six
and y is plus six so they actually
intersect some place around here instead
i drew these the lines probably look
something more like that
but that's pretty cool now we actually
solved for two of a two variables using
two equations
let's see how much time i have i think
we have time to do another problem
so let's say i had the points and i'm
gonna write them in two different colors
again
minus 7
x
minus 4y
equals 9 and then the second equation is
going to be
x plus
2 y
is equal to 3. now if i were just doing
this just as fast as possible i would
probably multiply this equation times 7
and it would automatically cancel out
but that's the easy way i'm going to
show you that sometimes you might have
to multiply both equations and we're
going to
actually not in this case it's actually
let's just do it the fast way real fast
so let's multiply this bottom equation
by 7. and the whole reason why i want to
multiply but 7 is because i want this to
cancel out with this
so if you multiply 7 you get 7 x plus 14
y
is equal to 21. let's write that first
equation down
again minus 7x
minus 4y
is equal to 9.
now we just add this is a positive 7x it
just almost looks like a negative though
okay so that's zero 14 minus 4y
plus 10y
is equal to 30
y is equal to 3.
and now we just substitute back either
one of these equations let's do that one
x plus 2 times 2 times y that's 2 times
3
x plus 6 equals 3. so we get x plus a
negative 3. that one was super easy
the intercept hope i didn't do it too
fast well you can pause it and watch it
again if you have to
okay
so
these two lines intersect at the point
negative 3
comma three
let's do one more
this one's harder
i think it will okay so it's negative
three x
minus 9 y
is equal to 66
we have minus 7x
plus 4 y
is equal to minus 71. so here it's not
obvious what we have to do is if we want
to count let's say we want to cancel out
the y's first
what we do is we try to make both of
them equal to the least common multiple
of of 9 and 4. so if we multiply the top
equation by 4
we get
i'll do it right here let's multiply it
by 4 times 4
we'll get
minus 12
x
minus 36 y
is equal to 4 times 6
240
plus 24
is 264
right i hope that's right and we
multiply the second equation by 9 so
it's
minus 63
x
plus
36 y
is equal to
let's see that's 639
there's a big number 639
okay now we add the two equations
minus 12
minus 63 that's minus 75
x
these cancel out
equals
264. so let's see what's 639
minus
264. see i do this in real time i don't
use some kind of solution thing or
solution manual or something see 13
and 5
70.
i don't know if i'm right but we'll
we'll see
so this is since it's actually the
negative on the 639 this is minus 375
and i know that
75 goes into 300 four times so
x
is equal to 5 because
75 times 5
is 375. we just divided both sides by 75
so if x is 5 we just substitute back
into let's let's use this equation
so we get
minus 3
times 5
minus 9y
is equal to 66. so we get minus 15
minus 9y
equals 66
minus 9y
is equal to 81
and then we get
y is equal to minus 9.
so the answer is five comma minus nine i
think you're ready to do some systems of
equations now have fun